This new project that I'm in
charge of really has me stumped.
Do you mind if I think out loud for
a bit Winston?
Thanks.
I have a ton of data about websites and
I want to be able to search through them
by which pages have links to each other,
there's an issue though.
I can't get a clear mental picture
of what they would look like and
I don't know which data type is best for
modeling connections between web pages.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Do you think I should use a graph?
What's that?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Right.
That's a lot of technical mumbo jumbo.
But I gather a graph is a data structure
designed to show relationships
between objects.
Sounds great.
I can't wait to learn more.